comme plusieurs états du sud des
États-Unis le Nevada suspanise
18% de ceux qui s'apprêtent à voter sont
latino américain
Lydia né au Mexique a grandi au Texas et
la déménager à Las Vegas en 2019
a eu des parents démocrates
Las Vegas il constate que la relation
entre le Parti démocrate et les latinos
américains les plus qu'elle était venu
plus que jamais le parti républicain
mise sur cette communauté
d'autant plus qu'aujourd'hui ces
auditeurs peste contre l'inflation
qui aurait coûté une moyenne de 10000
dollars en un an à chaque ménage du
Nevada un des États les plus touchés
Lorena et l'ami de Lydia elles sont
convaincus que Joe Biden a alimenté
l'inflation en donnant trop d'argent aux
Américains
continuera de s'éloigner des démocrates
comment fleurir par exemple ou le
phénomène a commencé
mais le plus gros syndicat du Nevada
dont 60% des membres sont hispanophones
appuient les candidats démocrates au
moins
l'organisation très efficace pour
mobiliser les lectorat fait de la
réélection de la sénatrice démocratique
sortante Catherine Cortez masto une
priorité
[Musique]
la lutte s'annonce série perdre ce siège
pourrait faire basculer le Sénat dans le
camp des républicains
extrêmes
la plupart des latinos sont d'origine
mexicaine le spectre du socialisme
brandit par les républicains fais-moi
peur quand Floride par exemple
rassemblement partisan où se trouvait le
fils de Donald Trump
il était un des rares hispanophone sur
place mais il continue de croire que sa
communauté choisira les valeurs
républicaines
elle veut même sécuriser la frontière
avec le Mexique son pays natal
[Musique]